welcome to this video playing the Jedi
Return of the Jedi is this a way to
pronounce it excellent in Dagobah oh
that's funny yeah this is a singapore
right yeah okay let's see I'm just
playing our normal simple kind of
development scheme here is you three
here I know okay I think there is d 5 in
this particular position maybe let's
let's do that and see that I don't get
done and a passive position early on hmm
interesting huh a chick d phi is gone
Queenie form looks a bit tricky this
position here I don't know the theory
here could be tricky so yeah let's take
that okay make sure that i actually get
the pawn back yeah that looks
comfortable for wine yeah just see six
I'm not sure about it this this is also
a pretty solid way to play don't really
expect him to take but if he does I can
might as well enter the move Bishop g4
g5 sorry he looks more normal oh cool i
thought i did that i didn't expect at
all interesting move so let's just do
this we should be six should be six
anyway I guess John White is a bit more
active him but I don't think I'm
substantially worse okay so maybe it
wants to cheat and play d5 interesting
95 95 94 ok so if he wants to double
their I don't think it's a huge problem
yeah it's a bit difficult to do
something as black um okay so what is
this Bishop g4 Bishop f6 queen d 7 i'm
going to grab this material and ask
questions later it's a nice little trick
that I hope is working pling he has to
move the Queen and then I take his rook
winning an exchange ultimately yeah I
saw this trick one or two most earlier
that this is possibly in the position I
didn't expect him to play a rook to d1
mmm you see does he have something great
job I mean I really only see ya you
gather but I can take on age 30 why this
is not a bad position they're
threatening Bishop g4 again and the
bishop hangs on f6 oh don't really see
the point here no chief or maybe or
something I don't get it ah ok Quinn to
g5 is what he wants to do but I can go
back to evade it's still kind of a
double attack and the bishop hangs I
mean I can just take the bishop right I
cannot just take the bishop he's got
night if for is this a problem
totally sure about this Nigel form
should be seven that still looks a bit
tricky you know I was thinking my
initial idea was this and I think it is
good he has Queen g5 I go back to f8 and
the rookie is still hanging on d1 and
I'm threatening h6 after which she has
to move the Queen and then I take the
bishop quite comfortably because i have
Bishop g7 all of the time to defend my
king so it's still a double threat
against his rook end with age six and I
don't really see a defense to that maybe
I could have taken the bishop but this
is what I had yeah I can take it from
here why not and d 1 is hanging
completely then white resides that was
nice to 516 so I'm one point short of my
all-time high that's cool so let's look
at the profile there yeah it's what do
we have to 5 16 and my all-time high was
25 17 but two weeks ago okay so let's
have a look at this game I liked it that
was quite nice okay just it was all very
normal chest normal moose yeah Bishop b5
was interesting okay I think c6 looks
very normal here getting pieces out mmm
rook e8 yeah i was thinking he might do
this sorry of course this and maybe d 5
194 that was what I expected I thought
it was about equal here this this thing
I thought Bishop sorry Bishop b5 may be
here but I'm not sure now computer gives
equal yeah I can always take here on d5
to simplify it to it raw okay you went
there and I now this Bishop move hits I
mean I had seen this idea earlier with
Queen g7 so what is the computer giving
just Queen d3m this is and it gives
equal interestingly enough because of
this this this and now Queen f3 with
compensation for white hmm interesting
yeah okay this is hanging and he has d
594 and some ideas to maybe activate the
bishop there in case of a queen move on
in case of Queen age 5 first interesting
hmm yeah that makes quite some sense
interesting position I think this is
just losing probably yeah it just lose
it just loses takes went here and okay
the computer as I expected gives rookie
one check jigs and winning I wasn't
totally sure really but yeah he doesn't
really have an something Bishop f5 is
always defending him now okay I should
have done that that such as easier but i
think i want to check but I think my
move is also good yeah they'd also win
so cool computer gives minus three here
and to be sure fa this was what was my
original idea and it does work it's
still it's just a double attack here if
he moves the rook let's say I'm playing
age six and now Queen has to move and
then I'm oops check then I'm checking
and now my bishop is here to defend yeah
well I mean it was a bit it was
unnecessary and what what um I just just
taking what's easier instead of this
Bishop f8 business here but okay it was
winning so that that is what
okay cool thanks for watching